Film Courage: Someone on Twitter had responded
to a Tweet that we sent out.
The Tweet was one of our videos which was
“Which scripts does Hollywood want?
Most screenwriters are writing the wrong ones.”
So we had a gentleman ask well “This is
a pivotal issue.
Do I write what I know and what moves me or
do I write what producers are looking for?”
I realize this is a ever going question.
Daniel Stamm, Writer/Director: It might not
be as black and white because what you know
and what moves you might not have to be so
literal.
Just because you were (whatever) a painter
doesn’t mean you have to write a script
about painting but it can be any creative
expression or any subtext in that or anything
that I think emotionally you know is different
from the specifics of the literal translation
of that.
So if you can make those two things overlap.
Of course I’m working on a TV show right
now that has a lot to do with ambition.
And obviously the protagonist on that show
pushes it to the maximum where I in real life
have never pushed it.
But I know what it feels like to have an ambition
to the point of I would do anything, I would
die, I have to do this!
So then I can take that feeling and infuse
it into my character but that does mean that
the character necessarily needs to literally
(wants to) achieve the same thing that I wanted
to achieve back then.
So I think if there is any way to…I think
it’s definitely wrong to reject this notion
because I hear that again and again at film
schools when I meet the graduating class or
something there is this vibe of stick to your
plans, don’t sell out.
Where I’m always like “Good luck with
that one!”
But if there is any way for you to not stick
to your plans, not sell out and still tell
the story that you want to tell well…that
might be the greatest version of it all because
you will not change Hollywood, your stuff
just won’t get made.
And if you want to do the indie thing, great.
And there might change and you might be part
of change but that’s a very slow process.
So instead of rejecting what producers want
and what the mainstream is and instead of
labelling that as pure negative but just going
“Can I give them what they think is going
to be commercial and popular because I want
my movie to be seen by as many people as possible
too.
If I don’t have to compromise and sacrifice
the essence and the DNA of the story I am
passionate about then I will try to achieve
that.
So maybe that’s an answer to that?
I don’t think it’s either/or.
You just have to ignore the screaming of both
sides that are making it sound as if it’s
one or the other and just come from your story
side and see if you can combine both and want
to make both worlds work for your story rather
than working against either of those.
Film Courage: It reminds me of a quote I saw
on someone’s car (it was a bumper sticker).
Even though it was many years ago I still
remember the exact scene and it is ‘In order
to change the system, you have to become part
of the system.”
And I’m sure I’ll look up the quote and
it will be “Oh?
So and so said that.”
But it sounds similar for making movies in
some sense?
Daniel: I’m sure they are a lot of different
ways to go.
I just know that the single focus on stick
to your plans and don’t compromise is not
the wisest answer.
And there are definitely examples, probably
where people who did that changed the world
and they changed film and all of that so I
don’t want to negate that either but it’s
not as easy as film schools will have it sound
as if it’s the go to thing “Of course
I’m an artist.
Of course I won’t compromise.
Of course I’ll stick to my plans.”
If you are in Hollywood and you can work with
Hollywood you might go faster than if you
have to work against Hollywood.
Film Courage: Makes sense.